si varias explosiones se han escuchado
en odessa varios misiles han impactado
en esa ciudad costera ucraniana y han
sido lanzados desde la península de
crimea ocupada por el ejército ruso
desde el año 2014 también explosiones en
gerson en hipo petros y las sirenas
antiaéreas que están sonando en
prácticamente toda la geografía
ucraniana donde nos encontramos en hard
kiss en pleno frente en la situación a
estas horas es bastante tranquila pero
en la ofensiva continúa están
recuperando pueblos de la zona del norte
de esta región aunque el alcalde pide a
los ciudadanos que no se acerquen a sus
pueblos para ver el estado de sus casas
porque la situación es todavía muy
inestable en la zona norte y sur de la
región de jarque es más hoy se les que
ha pedido a los ciudadanos que hagan
caso de las
sirenas antiaéreas y que por favor se
resguarden en los refugios al ser hoy un
día muy estratégico y muy celebrado en
la vecina rusia